hi there my name is peter badu and i
work in the department of mathematics
mit and today i'm going to share with
you our recent work on physics-informed
dynamic mode decomposition and this is a
collaborative project between myself
nathan coats and steve brunton at the
university of washington beverly mckeon
at caltech and benjamin hermann at the
university of chile
and this project was focused on
extending the dynamic mode decomposition
to situations where we have prior
physical knowledge about the system
we're studying
so i'm going to begin with an
introduction a reminder of what dmd is
what dynamic mode decomposition is and
in recent years it's become one of the
leading algorithms for data-driven
system identification
so dmd has three main steps and like in
any machine learning or data driven
algorithm the first step is the
collection and organization of data
so dmd works with data that is arranged
in a specific way it works with data
that consists of snapshots of a system
at different points in time
so in this case the system at hand is
the flow past the cylinder and the
snapshots are of vorticity measurements
at each point on this spatial grid
so these x vectors are going to be very
very tall
vectors they're going to have tens or
hundreds of thousands or more entries
and we're going to take a few snapshots
a few pictures of this system at a few
points in time so you see i have m
snapshots in this case
so we're going to take these m snapshots
we're going to arrange them into two
matrices an x matrix and a y matrix
and the columns of these matrices are
just the snapshots at different times
and they're arranged sequentially in
order
and the difference between the y and the
x matrix is simply that the columns of
the y matrix are the columns of the x
matrix but just shifted to the left in
other words the columns of the y matrix
are the elements of the x matrix but
advance forward one time step
dmd seeks to model the data that we've
generated that we've collected as if it
were generated by a linear dynamical
system
so mathematically
we assume that the data satisfies this
type of relation that there is a matrix
a
such that um for each xk we can
represent the measurement advance
forward one time step as as if we'd hit
xk with that matrix a and we don't know
a we want to find it as part of the
problem so to do that you can set up
this optimization problem where we're
trying to find an a that minimizes the
difference between y and ax
so this is just like saying i want to
find an a an a
that
gives as good predictions as i possibly
can it maps the xk as close as it
possibly can on to the xk plus one uh in
the the l2 sense
so this uh this norm here um
the little f is the frobenius norm and
as such we can solve this problem
because it's just a least squares
problem so you can write down the
solution analytically it's just that a
is y times the more penrose
pseudo-inverse
of x
although in practice those solutions are
the matrices are extremely large so we
don't want to actually construct this
explicitly we want to look at a low
dimensional version of this problem of
this operator
so to do that we project the matrix a
onto a low dimensional subspace here i'm
projecting onto the first r principal
components
and now we have that matrix that linear
operator in a tractable low-dimensional
space we can do various diagnostic tests
on it and by far the most popular ones
to do are to look at the so-called
dynamic modes so those are the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of that
matrix a
so the modes are the spatial modes they
are just the eigenvectors of that matrix
and the time dynamics are the
corresponding eigenvalues because
remember this a is representing a linear
dynamical system
so we could break up this data we could
decompose it just into a linear
combination of these spatial modes with
time dynamics corresponding to the
corresponding eigenvalues okay
and one really cool thing about dmd is
that it's completely equation free so
there was no point in this process that
i told the algorithm that we were
studying a fluid mechanics system or
that we
knew that this was an incompressible
flow
and as such the algorithm has been
applied to a huge variety of application
areas some of which have nothing really
obvious to do with each other so there's
great applicability of dmd
but one could say that that might be
indicative of a lost opportunity there
was no opportunity here to include our
physical knowledge about the system
there was no opportunity to include
any conservation laws any imbalances or
any symmetries that we might know after
having done centuries worth of physics
work to understand fluid mechanics
so we said to address that in this work
we asked the question how can we include
that fire that prior physical knowledge
into dmd and this physics informed dmd
is what we came up with
so to come up with physics the physics
informed dmd we had to go back and look
at the original dmd algorithm and try
and reformat it in a way that allows
physics to be seamless seamlessly
integrated therein
so one way of looking at dmd is that it
seeks a low rank matrix that best
represents the data
so this point goes back to the comment i
made in passing that usually we project
the matrix a onto a low dimensional
subspace
so another way of thinking about that is
that
dmd is approximately solving this
minimization problem given a specific
target rank r it seeks a rank r or less
matrix a that best maps x on to y the
best advances the data forward
in time
this is approximately what the
regression step of dmd is doing and one
way of thinking about these low rank
matrices is that they can be factorized
into these these two parts um into a
set of r columns instead of r rows
and this is representative of modal
physics so
if i'm studying a modal system a system
where there's just a few dominant modes
that characterize the behavior of the
system
then i just need to understand those
modes
analogously if i'm looking at a low rank
matrix i don't need to understand like
every single element in this matrix i
just need to understand
these two columns and these two rows
and low rank matrices have additional
computational properties which make them
really attractive like they're very
efficient to work with in terms of
memory and you can do fast computations
and as such they've really dominated a
lot of the dmd literature and the model
order reduction literature as well
but low rank matrices aren't the only
type of interesting or useful matrix
structure out there there's a whole
world of different matrices that might
be
more relevant or more useful for your
physical application
for example we might be studying a
quantum mechanical system and we know
that the observable we're working with
is hermitian
or self-adjoint then we might seek a
symmetric matrix as opposed to a low
rank matrix
or we might be studying a causal system
some some system that has some spatial
hierarchy
then a low rank matrices matrix might
not be the best choice we might actually
be more interested in a causal matrix
that has a sort of upper triangular
structure
so we don't want to be tied to a low
rank representation we want to have the
flexibility to include additional
physics
with additional matrix structures
so
that's how we include this physical
knowledge into dmd we
we don't necessarily constrain the
matrix to have a low rank we instead
constrain it to lie in what we call a
matrix manifold a physics and form
matrix manifold so that's just a fancy
way of saying we require the matrix a
to be a certain type of matrix
like i mentioned before a symmetric
matrix or an upper triangular matrix
and that choice of manifold that the
choice of class of matrix
should be informed by our physical prior
knowledge of the system
so you can
actually solve many of these problems in
closed form by which i mean just in
terms of standard linear algebra objects
like an svd or a polar decomposition or
a qr decomposition
so all of these different matrix
structures you can solve for just using
these standard
very simple linear algebra operations
and
on this slide i've illustrated the
physical
structure like self-adjointness the
corresponding matrix structure and where
you can find the solution of that that
optimization problem that i showed on
the previous slide
so you can see that in a few places the
solutions are new so we've generated new
solutions to these optimization problems
but this physics informed optimization
problem is actually pretty old it goes
back
very far
actually all the way to greek mythology
there was a famous character called
procrustes in greek mythology and he was
a bandit who lived on a road
in greece
and he would invite weary travelers into
his home and he would tell them that he
had a magical bed and no matter what
size they were they would fit on the bed
and the travelers were really excited by
this because it sounded like they were
going to get a great night's sleep on
this perfect fitting bed
um but what they realized was that when
they went to procrasti's home
is that the reason they would fit on the
bed is that he would either
amputate their limbs or elongate them so
that they stretched on to the bed and
i'm not just telling this story for fun
but actually the optimization problem i
showed previously is um often called a
procrustes problem
the reason being that every term in this
optimization has a corresponding role in
this legend so we could say that the
victim is the matrix x
the bed is the matrix y this is the
circle magical bed and then the
treatment is the matrix a so
procrastinator trying to find the
treatment that best maps the matrix x
onto the matrix y the treatment that
best maps the victim onto the bed
okay and these have been studied quite
slow in the statistical literature so
there were a few prior solutions that we
could draw on in this project and the
link between procrosses and dmd is a
novel connection and it allows us to
leverage a large amount of external
literature into the across these
problems for these new dmd applications
okay
so one of the most basic physical
principles is that of conserved
quantities and one of the most basic
principles therein is that of energy
conservation
so it seems very natural that we should
seek a version of dmd that preserves the
energy of the state it doesn't allow
energy to to grow or to dissipate
so
in terms of mathematics we might seek a
matrix a that preserves the energy of
the state so if this e corresponds the
energy of the state then we want the
energy of x k to be the same as the
energy of a of xk
and it's pretty common to model the
energy as just the l2 norm of the state
so that the energy is just the two norm
squared of the the state that we're
working with here
so if you want the energy to preserve
then this equation has to hold and if it
holds for all such xk
then that's equivalent to saying that
this matrix a is is unitary
it has eigenvalues lying on the unit
circle and it has orthogonal
columns and rows
that's like geometrically saying that
the model has
is either a reflection or a rotation
so the procrastination's problem this is
actually the original procrastination's
problem um it takes this form we're
trying to find a unitary a an a that
satisfies this identity that minimizes
the difference between y and a of x and
it turns out that you can write down the
solution for that just in terms of an
svd so we can write down the exact
solution for this optimization problem
let's go now and apply that solution to
a physical problem so here we're working
with the double pendulum which is a
nonlinear problem
and we're working
with relatively small amplitude uh
perturbation so it's approximately
linear
and in the absence of any friction or
air resistance this system preserves
energy and the energy is the combination
of the
gravitational potential energy and the
kinetic energy so we know
that this system
has a conserved quantity it has uh
conserved energy
and we're going to apply dmd and
physics-informed dmd to this system
but there are two hiccups the first is
that we're going to take noisy
measurements of this system so i'm going
to measure the thetas like the angles of
the red and the orange
bars
and i'm going to add some gaussian noise
to them there's another source of noise
which is modeling noise we're modeling
this non-linear system as a linear
system so there's going to be
some unmodeled terms in our model
and the result you can see down here is
that if we train a pi dnd model in a dmd
model and try and reconstruct the data
well dmd does very poorly because its
eigenvalues end up being artificially
smaller than they should be
whereas physics informed dmd is
constrained to have eigenvalues on that
unit circle it's a it's a unitary
operator it's eigenvalues have to have
absolute value one
uh and as a result um you can see that
it doesn't let energy just go to zero
but it preserves the energy and it
obtains a really excellent
reconstruction here so the poor
performance of dmd is
very well documented in the presence of
noise and there are various algorithms
to address that and this is another
another method you could use that
includes the physical knowledge as a
regularizer that can alleviate the
effects of noise
okay
another very common physical property is
shift in variance and by shifting
variance we mean that the system we're
studying looks the same no matter how we
translate our view of the system
so such systems are common in
constant coefficient pd's and
convolutional integral equations
another way of thinking about these is
that
the operator or the system should
commute with the shift operator so the
shift operator takes in
functions and it just shifts their
arguments
if our system is shift invariant then it
should commute with that shift operator
in other words shifting the input is the
same as shifting the output
if we translate that mathematical
statement into the matrix world then
we'd see that the the matrix a that
satisfies this relation
is
circulant it has constant
diagonals with periodicity
so if we want to tackle a dmd problem
where we know that the operator should
be shifting variant then we can set up
this problem where we have the same cost
function except now a is required to
have this circular structure
this optimization problem is actually
pretty easy to solve there's just three
facts that we need to employ
the first fact is that circular matrices
are diagonalizable by dft matrices
so that means that we can write this
matrix a
in diagonal form where the the left and
right vectors are the
discrete fourier transform matrix
so this is just saying that eigenva
eigenvectors of shift invariant systems
um are just sines and cosines that's all
this relation says and then we can plug
in this representation for a and now our
task is to find this little a little a
hat which the eigenvector eigenvalues of
the system
so we've simplified the problem a bit
the next thing to notice is that the dft
matrix is unitary
and since the frobenius norm is in is
unitarily invariant
i can move this f star from this term
to this term and get rid of the star
that's just uh by hitting that whole
whole um
expression with an f
so now i've got this problem and now i
can actually break this problem into its
constituent parts by which i mean we can
decouple this frobenius norm via its
rose so the frubinius norm you often see
it as the sum of the l2 of the columns
it's also the sum of the l2 norm of the
rose and that's what we do here
and now we just have a one-dimensional
regression problem
we we've decoupled all of these ais we
just want to find an ai that best maps
f of y
uh
best maps f of x onto f of y so you can
write that solution it's just a linear
regression here i've i've written the
sort of matlab backslash notation but
you can also write that in terms of the
pseudo inverse or the at the transpose
of fx and so on
we can apply this shift and variant
principle to some pretty complicated
examples like the three-dimensional
navier-stokes equations
so in this case
we're looking at a realistic initial
condition that could be realized in
experiments and we're seeing how it
propagates with this parabolic
background flow so this is posoyflow
it's a pretty high state dimension with
about 200 000 elements in each state
factor and we only have 300 temporal
snapshots i'm only looking at this and
taking pictures of it at 300 different
points in time so it's a very
underdetermined system
we can apply dmd to this and seek a dmd
model which would necessarily be low
rank it would have to have this this
structure where we're separating a into
its modal constituents
that would be quite difficult because
the navier-stokes equations have this
convective term which is quite difficult
for dmd and these low rank
representations to capture
but we know something about this system
just by looking at it we can see that
there's a certain spatial structure
there's homogeneity in two directions
in the x and the z direction
there isn't homogeneity in the y
direction because of this um parabolic
background flow
but if we know this physics we can then
encode that using the ideas from the
previous slide into the into a pi dmd
model so now we're not just seeking a
low rank a but we're seeking an a that
respects that shift in variance so we've
done that by encoding a to have
circulant blocks
on two levels
and if we do that then you can see that
the eigenvalues learned by pi dmd are
much more accurate than those learned by
standard dmd
specifically
the least damped eigenvalues which are
really the most important ones are
obtained very accurately whereas
standard dmd doesn't really learn any of
them
okay
something else that we can include with
this physics and form perspective is
spatial locality
so spatial locality just means that
states that are spatially local to one
another that are near to one another
are more closely coupled than states
that are far apart from one another
so that's a hallmark of partial
differential equations where the the
rate of change of the state is a
function of derivatives of the state uh
it's not
a hallmark of say integral systems where
you are integrating your system over a
spatial domain
so
this is a good example of a spatially
local problem where we have a um
an advection diffusion term with a
spatially variable
advection term there
and you can see a bit how this evolves
um this is in the absence of forcing so
the f term is zero
and we're going to attack this problem
with dmd with a standard dmd method and
then our physics inform dmd but we're
going to enforce spatial locality in the
physics-informed dmd model and
specifically you can see here that means
we're going to let the
pi dmd model
only be
um tridiagonal that means the state can
only be affected by states adjacent to
it
okay
you can see what happens if we do that
the model learned by dmd has this low
rank structure the model learned by pi
emd is constrained to have this
tri-diagonal structure
um the ensuing resolvent norms and
response modes and forcing modes are
therefore much more accurate
you can see that the
response modes here
are very well captured so the yellow is
the pi dmd and the grey is the ground
truth
and also for the these resolvent norms i
should mention that that these
quantities the resolvent more norms and
these modes
are representations of um
the optimal forcing function f in the
frequency domain so if you wanted to
cause a
as large a possible perturbation to your
state c then you should choose one of
these response modes sorry one of these
forcing modes to produce a response mode
of
uh of a norm of a magnitude that
corresponds to these curves
so this is a this is resolvent analysis
specifically data-driven resolvent
analysis
another way of thinking about this is
that we're basically doing a data-driven
finite difference
method
instead of applying a finite difference
matrix we're trying to learn the best
finite difference matrix that represents
the data
okay
so here's a brief summary of all the
systems that we've studied using this
physics informed dmd
there's a few different type of physical
systems including quantum mechanics
fluid dynamics
even a neural um
a neuron equation here
there's a lot of information here so
i'll just draw your attention to these
red
columns and the point is that physics
informed dmd is much better able to
identify the eigenvalues of the system
if we tell it
something about the physics of the
underlying system
okay
so i'll wrap up here i presented this
physics informed dmd algorithm which is
a new method of seamlessly integrating
prior physical knowledge into the dmd
framework and it does so by enforcing
the learned dmd model to lie in a
specific matrix manifold
once we've calculated that that matrix
we can then look at its diagnostic
properties such as its dynamic modes or
its spectrum or its resolvent modes
through a sequence of examples we've
shown that the models learned by d by pi
dmd have greater generalization power
and they're less sensitive to noise and
they require fewer training samples and
one big reason for that is that uh we're
effectively telling dmd something about
data that it hasn't observed when we're
telling the system that it's shift
invariant or we're telling it that it's
it preserves energy we're giving it
additional information so it can
generalize more powerfully
and these pi dmd models usually have
fewer degrees of freedom than standard
dmd models so that's why they require
for your training samples additionally
we've derived what we call exact
solutions just meaning that the
solutions are in terms of standard
linear algebra objects and these are all
available on a github and the paper is
also available on archive so i invite
you to go and read it there thank you
for listening please get in touch if you
have any questions about anything